The Hugging Face Datasets library: A Quick
overview. The Hugging Face Datasets library
is a library that provides an API to quickly
download many public datasets and preprocess them.
In this video we will explore how to do that. The
downloading part is easy: with the load_dataset
function, you can directly download and cache a
dataset from its identifier on the Dataset hub.
Here we fetch the MRPC dataset from
the GLUE benchmark, which is a dataset
containing pairs of sentences where the
task is to determine the paraphrases.
The object returned by the load_dataset function
is a DatasetDict, which is a sort of dictionary
containing each split of our dataset. We can
access each split by indexing with its name.
This split is then an instance of
the Dataset class, with columns
(here sentence1, sentence2. label and idx) and
rows. We can access a given element by its index.
The amazing thing about the Hugging Face Datasets
library is that everything is saved to disk using
Apache Arrow, which means that even if your
dataset is huge you won't get out of RAM:
only the elements you request are loaded in
memory. Accessing a slice of your dataset is
as easy as one element. The result is then a
dictionary with list of values for each keys
(here the list of labels, the list of first
sentences and the list of second sentences). The
features attribute of a Dataset gives us more
information about its columns. In particular,
we can see here it gives us the correspondence
between the integers and names for the labels.
0 stands for not equivalent and 1 for equivalent.
To preprocess all the elements of our dataset,
we need to tokenize them. Have a look at the
video "Preprocess sentence pairs" for a refresher,
but you just have to send the two sentences to the
tokenizer with some additional keyword arguments.
Here we indicate a maximum length of 128
and pad inputs shorter than this length,
truncate inputs that are longer. We put all of
this in a tokenize_function that we can directly
apply to all the splits in our dataset with the
map method. As long as the function returns a
dictionary-like object, the map method will add
new columns as needed or update existing ones.
To speed up preprocessing and take advantage
of the fact our tokenizer is backed by Rust
thanks to the Hugging Face Tokenizers library,
we can process several elements at the same time
to our tokenize function, using the batched=True
argument. Since the tokenizer can handle list
of first/second sentences, the tokenize_function
does not need to change for this. You can also use
multiprocessing with the map method, check out its
documentation! Once this is done, we are almost
ready for training: we just remove the columns we
don't need anymore with the remove_columns method,
rename label to labels (since the models
from Hugging Face Transformers expect that)
and set the output format to our desired
backend: torch, tensorflow or numpy. If needed,
we can also generate a short sample
of a dataset using the select method.